in this video we will talk about the
urea cycle now urea cycle is also known
as the krebs hence elite cycle before
beginning the actual cycle let's have an
overview about what happens in the urea
cycle as some of you may know that the
amino acid metabolism produces free
ammonia and this ammonia is toxic to the
body and it cannot be excreted properly
by the body so the urea cycle is a
biochemical pathway in the body which
converts the free ammonia into urea the
urea is comparatively non-toxic to
ammonia and it can be easily excreted by
the body in urine and this conversion of
ammonia into urea is known as the urea
cycle the part of the urea cycle takes
place in the cytoplasm and part of it
takes place in the mitochondria now
let's suppose this part of the cell is
the mitochondria and this part of the
cell is the cytoplasm the urea cycle
actually begins inside the mitochondria
the combination of carbon dioxide and
ammonium ions produces carbamoyl
phosphate this reaction requires two ATP
molecules and it also requires the
enzyme carbamoyl phosphate synthetase
one after the formation of carbamoyl
phosphate this combines with the amino
acid or anything and lead to the
formation of citrulline now this
reaction is catalyzed by the enzyme
ornithine transcarbamylase now in the
next step the citrulline is transported
into the cytoplasm it combines with the
amino acid as part 8 and lead to the
formation of our Geno succinate this
reaction is catalyzed by the enzyme our
genome succinate synthetase now in the
next step the enzyme our genome 16s acts
upon the r0 succinate and lysis it to
produce two molecules the fumarate and
the arginine
the last step of the urea cycle the
enzyme our genus acts on the arginine
and lysis it to produce urea and/or
Athene the ornithine is utilized back
into the urea cycle whereas the urea is
a soluble compound it dissolves into a
blood and is transported to the kidneys
to be excreted in the form of urine so
this was a short description of the urea
cycle I hope you find this video
informative make sure to share like and
subscribe to our Channel
thank you so much for watching this
video